Et sinon, qu’est-ce qu’on mange ?
Bœuf bourguignon revisité ?
Ah, si tu voulais pas faire la cuisine, fallait le dire hein.
Mais non, c’est la bouffe du futur.
C’est appétissant, non ?
Nan.
La nourriture de demain semble être le nouveau dada des innovations hi-tech.
En même temps, avec près de 9 milliards d’humains à nourrir,
un réchauffement climatique qui s’emballe et des ressources en eau douce limitées,
on ne peut pas vraiment continuer à produire du boeuf et des légumes à grand coup d’eau et d’engrais. Innover en matière alimentaire semble donc être une bonne idée.
C’est ainsi que ces dernières années ont vu naître un nombre phénoménal de solutions miracles, notamment pour produire des protéines.
L’exemple le plus courant, ce sont bien sûr les insectes et les vers.
Ils font déjà partie du repas dans certaines cultures et le fort rendement de la production intéresse sérieusement les industriels.
Avec 10 tonnes d’aliments, on peut produire 9 tonnes de protéines d’insectes alors qu’on ne produira que 1 à 5 tonnes avec les bovins, les porcins ou la volaille.
Certains préfèrent miser sur les algues comme la spiruline qui croît de façon naturelle dans des eaux salées, chaudes et ensoleillées.
Mais les protéines et les vitamines qu’elle contient restent plus difficile à assimiler pour l’homme.
Autre option, beaucoup plus chère : le steak in vitro.
Il s'agit tout simplement d’un amas de cellules musculaires qui se multiplient dans des boîtes de Pétri
avec un milieu de culture suffisamment riche, contenant notamment des hormones, des facteurs de croissance, des antibiotiques et des fongicides.
Miam !
Autour de 1000 euros le gramme, ce sera peut être le caviar du futur.
Mais ceux qui ont le vent en poupe ce sont les repas en poudres.
Équilibrés, faciles à produire et rapides à manger,
ils se présentent comme une solution alternative aux repas traditionnels.
C'est le fantasme de l’aliment miracle qu’on nous sert depuis des années en science-fiction.
Et c’est d’ailleurs en référence au film Soleil vert qu’en 2013, la première marque américaine de repas à boire choisit son nom.
Dans ce film mythique, les ressources sont épuisées et les humains se nourrissent d’aliments de synthèse que Soylent fabrique à partir de… cadavres euthanasiés.
Donc un choix marketing audacieux.
Mais bizarrement, aucune de ces solutions alimentaires miracles n’a connu de succès vraiment retentissant.
Ces aliments du futur sont en fait des aliments disruptifs.
Un concept inventé par l'anthropologue industrielle Fanny Parise,
pour désigner ces produits qui étaient jusque-là absents de notre culture alimentaire et qu’on nous propose désormais de manger, par le biais d’une innovation technologique, sociétale ou marketing.
Et forcément, ça crée de nombreuses résistances.
En premier lieu, une part de la population refuserait de tester ces nouveaux aliments simplement par néophobie alimentaire.
Cette réticence à manger des aliments inconnus, est un trait commun à de nombreuses espèces d’omnivores
et serait à l’origine un comportement de protection contre les empoisonnements ou les intoxications alimentaires.
Aujourd'hui certes, nous connaissons mieux notre environnement,
mais nous développons une défiance de plus en plus grande envers l'industrie alimentaire, en réaction notamment à de  nombreux scandales sanitaires.
Au delà des besoins énergétiques, ce qui va influencer nos choix d’alimentation, c'est le plaisir de manger,
et surtout la perspective du plaisir que l’on aura à la dégustation d’un aliment.
En 2015, le neurologue Serge Luquet et son équipe ont montré l’implication de 2 types de voies nerveuses dans la régulation de l’alimentation chez les mammifères.
Un premier réseaux de neurones qui va répondre principalement aux besoins énergétiques,
j’ai la dalle, il faut que je mange,
et deuxième un réseau de neurones essentiellement lié au plaisir que procure la nourriture.
C’est ce deuxième réseau qui va guider une partie de notre attirance pour ce qui est beau et bon.
Et c’est aussi lui qui est responsable du comportement qu’on appelle “confort feeding”,
le fait de manger pour se réconforter, de façon totalement déconnectée de ses besoins alimentaires.
Je ne vois pas du tout de quoi tu parles.
L’aspect autant que le goût ou l’odeur joue donc un rôle clé
dans notre décision de manger ou non un aliment,
et on ne peut pas dire pour l’instant que ce soit très réussi pour les repas en poudre ou les protéines de synthèse.
Au delà de prendre du plaisir à manger et de nourrir notre corps, prendre un repas nourrit aussi et surtout le lien social.
Le repas collectif, chez les premiers hominidés était un élément nécessaire à la survie en groupe.
Il permettait de partager le gibier avec les plus faibles et de favoriser la communication au lieu de la compétition pour la nourriture.
Aujourd’hui, notre repas ne détermine plus notre survie, par contre la commensalité, donc le fait de partager un repas avec des convives,
reste un moment fort de sociabilisation.
Après tout, c’est vrai qu’on retrouve à travers les siècles et dans presque toutes les cultures humaines, des repas pour célébrer les moments importants en communauté.
- Qu’est-ce qu’on fait pour les fêtes, quelque soit la religion ?
- On mange !
- On mange.
- Et qu’est-ce qu’on fait pour un anniversaire ?
- On mange !
Qu’est-ce qu’on fait pour un mariage ?
- Et on boit !
Oui, c’est pas faux, on boit aussi, mais l’alcool, ce sera pour une autre fois.
En attendant, c’est pas pour rien que les cuisines de l’Elysée ou des ambassades se payent des cuisiniers 3 étoiles,
c’est une question de diplomatie.
Et ça ne date pas d’hier, parce que, à l’Antiquité aussi, il y avait une dimension sociale au repas.
Oui, totalement, c’est une dimension sociale, en effet, politique.
Il ne faut pas perdre de vue que l’Antiquité grecque, par exemple, c’est une très grande période de temps,
sur une très grosse aire géographique qui varie sur les siècles, etc.
Donc, les pratiques aussi elles varient, elles sont différentes en fonction des cités, en fonction des époques dans les cités.
Mais globalement, le banquet, notamment le banquet public, le banquet civique, c’est vraiment un moment d’échange politique.
On fait circuler les idées.
Y a suivant les cités une codification avec les rôles des citoyens plus riches qui font ci ou ça, ou  dans d’autres cités, c’est tout le monde, c’est un signe d’égalité et de partage entre tout citoyen.
Et voilà, et ça évolue au fil du temps, c’est pas tout le temps partout la même pratique, mais clairement, il y a une dimension sociale aussi,
d’éducation du jeune citoyen, où c’est un rituel aussi, tu apprends à te comporter en société.
Donc, on n’est pas du tout oisif à boire et manger tous couchés quoi.
Non, non, non. Bon, y a ça dans le banquet, évidemment, ça c’est clair.
Mais après, il y a aussi les sacrifices où on partage la viande commune.
Et puis, plus tard dans le temps, dans l’Antiquité plus tardive, par exemple, Plutarque, lui, il est saoulé par les banquets civiques et tout ça, c’est trop m’as-tu-vu, ça ne sert plus à rien pour lui.
Donc, il préfère les plus petits comités chez les privés etc.
Donc oui, dimension politique, sociale mais qui évolue.
Le 16 novembre 2010, le repas gastronomique des Français est la première des traditions culinaires enregistrées par l’UNESCO
sur la liste du patrimoine culturel immatériel de l'humanité.
Et ce n’est pas simplement le repas “entrée-plat-dessert” qui est distingué
mais une vraie pratique sociale, je cite : “un ensemble de rituels et de valeurs
avec en premier lieu, celui du partage alimentaire.
Le repas gastronomique met l’accent sur le fait d’être bien ensemble, le plaisir du goût”.
Donc, si cette distinction internationale a un goût si particulier pour les Français, ça n’est pas seulement parce qu’elle récompense leur amour immodéré pour la bouffe,
mais qu’elle reconnait la vertue sociale du repas.
Et ce partage alimentaire prend désormais une autre dimension à travers les média sociaux.
Eh oui, le #foodporn auquel certains s’adonnent sur Instagram,
a aussi une fonction sociale.
Basé sur le partage de photo appétissantes,
oui donc, elles font appel à notre circuit neuronal du plaisir,
le foodporn permet d’élargir l’espace de convivialité au delà des proches qui partagent notre repas, vers ceux qui ne peuvent pas être avec nous.
Mais aujourd’hui dans les pays développées, les régimes alimentaires particulier se multiplient :
sans allergènes, sans lactose, sans gluten, végétarien, locavore, bio, vegan, cachère, crudivore, sans porc, hyperprotéiné, chronobiologique, macrobiotique,...
Certes, adopter une alimentation particulière n’est en soi pas une nouveauté.
Dans la Grèce antique par exemple, certains groupes de pensée adoptaient un régime alimentaire spécifique.
Les Pythagoriciens par exemple étaient végétariens.
Mais aujourd’hui, les régimes particuliers sont très hétéroclites et relèvent d’un choix individuel.
Ils peuvent être de simples restrictions médicales, mais sont souvent le fruit de prises de position idéologique, religieuse, politique, ou d’une défiance envers l’industrie agro-alimentaire.
Evidemment, ces nouvelles pratiques alimentaires complexifient et même remettent en cause le principe de la commensalité,
en créant une exclusion, volontaire ou non, du repas partagé.
En étudiant l’intégration des particularismes alimentaires dans les repas, la psychosociologue Estelle Masson et l’anthropologue Claude Fischler notent une grande variabilité entre les pays anglo-saxons et les pays latins.
Aux Etats-Unis, au Royaume uni et dans les pays du nord de l’Europe, on aura tendance à satisfaire intégralement les exigences alimentaires, sans jamais les remettre en cause,
et en proposant à chaque convive un plat adéquat.
En France et en Italie, l’idée est plus souvent d’ajouter quelques plats compatibles avec les régimes particuliers, mais sans changer le plat principal partagé par la majorité.
Peut-être que, dans le pays du “repas gastronomique”, manifester une exigence alimentaire revient à affronter une pression sociale plus forte,
autrement dit à assumer d’être le chieur ou la chieuse de service.
Au final, dans tous les cas, l’idée est de préserver l’apparence d’un repas,
même si tous les convives n’ont pas mangé exactement les mêmes aliments.
Et cela laisse entrevoir ce à quoi pourrait ressembler le repas du futur.
Probablement pas un repas en gellule, mais plutot à une sorte de pique-nique partagé ou d’apéro dinatoire,
dans lequel chaque convive pourra picorer ce qu’il veut.
Merci d’avoir regardé cet épisode du Vortex, j’espère que vous n’avez pas trop faim.
N’hésitez pas à laisser un commentaire, abonnez-vous et rejoignez-nous sur le Discord.
Et puis je vous dis : “à très vite”.
Ça va aller.
Nan mais ça va être dégueulasse le futur.
- Mais nan regarde.
- Mais si.
T’as raison.
Ça va être dégueulasse.